a lot more because they've been on the
planet um for a longer period of time
but then if they haven't got a job or
not earning as much then it's like okay
what have you been doing all of this
time at your big age it just it doesn't
really i don't know it's hard
it's hard because you don't know
people's you know stories or backgrounds
yeah i mean i mean that just shows
though that like you are looking for
money in a way it might not be like that
thing but because they've reached a
certain age where you think they're not
going to earn any more money than this
so it does mean you do matter about it
i feel personally for me it's more an
opinion of like what my parents and what
their expectations of me are especially
like obviously being a woman living in a
patriarchal society like a lot of things
are not really geared towards women's
safety or women being able to earn as
much money as men or um being able to
reach high ceo positions
what are you talking about our whole
society is geared towards women women
make 70 to 80 of consumer buying
decisions our whole media is geared
towards women empowerment there's no
men's empowerment okay well i i don't
know this is this stick so i'm
definitely wrong here but i'm just
saying in terms of like um
you know
um maybe more so traditional values then
and the way that like women um see men
as
a way
a type of security or like a safety net
so to speak so when i'm looking at it
from kind of that perspective if we're
really looking at a man that is the
example 35 who's earning a lot less than
a female that is a lot younger then for
me personally would be questionable
because then bringing that home to my
family and my family's like okay so
you're a young woman how is your
potential husband going to be able to
look after you and not only you but your
children do you think it's fair to ask
men to provide traditional outcomes when
we're not traditional no no
it depends on the couple like
the the couple has to be compatible
together and it depends on whether they
um consider or value societal values in
their relationships no so i'm just
saying like by and large like i know
there's gonna be new you know what i
mean i know there's gonna be nuance but
i'm saying like by and large do you
think it's fair to to ask for
traditional outcomes when we're not
traditional women anymore what is your
definition of interest so not being a
traditional woman anymore so i would say
if you're not a virgin like you're not a
traditional woman
because a traditional woman like
traditionally women were virgins when
they got married
and a traditional outcome is when the
man is still expected to protect and
provide
so it's like we're asking for
traditional outcomes when we're not
traditional ourselves yeah because even
in your situation you were a bit
traditional yourself there because when
you answer that you you worry about what
your family's going to think then why
couldn't you be the provider like if you
truly felt that way why can't you that
it doesn't matter if the man's a nurse
and earning like 20k or whatever why
couldn't you be the big you know the
main thing so even in yourself your
answer's a bit
uh traditional yeah i guess so i feel
like that's maybe because i value like
my parents opinion but then also i
wouldn't want to be a provider like i
feel as though sometimes um women they
take on this big struggle of yeah i have
to do everything
um or they don't necessarily have the
support of like men um in order to like
reach their goals and aspirations and
they're looking after everyone else but
themselves so it's just like oh i
personally i wouldn't prefer to like be
like the main earner in my household
like i want to put my feet up i want to
relax like the struggle life is not for
me
the traditional ways like men want the
same as we do like you want to be
cleaned
cooked for being taken care of so would
you say modern women by and large offer
that because they also want purity in
youth and we don't offer either of those
things purity i don't think it's really
a major thing to be honest because we're
women really pure back then we don't
know 100 percent yeah so they say yeah
we can't guarantee that every question
for the men would you want a girl that
slept with 100 people no would you want
a girl that slept with a hundred people
no but my answer is probably different
to what you expect like because my
reason is just like i don't actually
care that it's a hundred people
it's just the fact that i wouldn't go
for that type of girl who is willing to
sleep with 100 people so it's not the
number that puts me off it's just then i
know that's that type of person like to
act but then you're basing her off the
number right well it's based off it's
based off of choices that she makes yeah
so like it's like if i was looking at a
guy and he cheated on every single girl
he'd been with like i could infer that
he's a cheater so if a girl's been
sleeping around for the past decade he
can first she's a hoe not exactly like
your your body count does not amount to
who you are well people do change as
well yeah but it amounts to your
decision-making abilities
but then that deter that those decision
abilities may be determined because of
like childhood trauma or like things
that that person has gone through or
experienced or experienced like
some negative that's true experience but
the world doesn't owe you understanding
yeah so so the guy
the guy like when you come to a guy he
doesn't owe you understanding and if you
come to him and he can tell you slipped
around like i think it's in his right to
not want to date you then i have a
question do you think that a male like
for us being women do you think
men owe us respect
um i mean i think everyone deserves like
a basic
level of like
i don't even want to say respects i
guess respect is earned but like human
decency
but i think like you should be selective
and who you date and i think men have a
right to be selective in who they date
and if they don't want to date a girl
that slept around i think that's
perfectly fine and i wouldn't want my
brother to date a girl that's like
banging the whole football team
at double standards because the male can
bang the whole cheerleading team
yeah because
because men and women are different
because a man has to become something in
order to sleep around
you're not gonna you're not gonna okay
you're not gonna sleep around with like
an overweight bomb
right
you forgot overweight bum comes up to
you you going on a date with him
i don't know it depends on the
confidence
but if we look at the data the results
speak for themselves one out of three
men are either virgins or haven't had
sex in the past year
so we don't owe them sex or
understanding for not being able to get
laid
just and that's the same way like men
don't owe us relationships if we've
slept around it makes me laugh as well
because if an ugly person comes up to
you in a club and gives you a compliment
or say something nice it comes across as
creepy yeah right that guy's a creep if
a handsome person or a good looking
person comes up to you you're flirting
like shy and stuff like that you know so
it it depends on the person who says
it's really i think that's right also
the equivalent to
men sleeping around not being feds
men saying oh like if i'm broke should
you still date me
so like women go for guys that are
established financially or that's what
they want even if they're looking
potential wise they won't date a good
looking bomb
for
too long it won't be long term okay so
what the saying you can't turn a hoe
into a housewife but how many hoes are
housewives right now yeah you're right
you're right i i
i actually agree with you to some level
like those girls do usually still get
married the problem is they leave they
get bored and statistically the data
supports that because a woman that's had
sex with more with that's a virgin when
she gets married has an 80 chance of a
happy marriage and if she has sex with
more than five people which most men
pray for nowadays it goes down it goes
down to like 25
is that a happy marriage or is that
settling we don't what do you what do
you mean like that the woman that was a
virgin and then married like well you
don't know how good her sex life is well
but you ask her if she's happy in her
marriage and there's 80 chance after 10
years she says yes i'm happy where the
girl that's had sex with more than five
people there's a 25 chance that she says
yes i'm happy so if i'm a dude and i'm
thinking hmm do i want to go with more
bodies or less bodies i'd pick less
bodies but that's because that's all she
knows isn't it like that's that's that's
all she the only person she is
so that's what she's going to be happy
with if you've tried and tested around
and obviously you know you're right
that's correct like the more you have to
compare it to but it's like
guys don't want to be compared to a
whole bunch of dudes that's not
attractive
what's wrong with
with being satisfied i mean
you know you're saying oh well i'm going
to go and test drive a whole lot of cars
before you decide which one you want to
spend the rest of your life with but
there again if some somebody just gave
you a car
you'd be happy with it
and and and isn't that in at the end of
the day isn't that the objective to be
happy
yeah
yeah so yeah but everyone if you know
there was a there was an old song in the
60s
if you can't be with the one you love be
the love the one you're with
yeah people haven't thought people have
this no it's not it's not separate the
thing is the only reason why you think
it's happening is because disney is yeah
disney has convinced you that you're
somehow or another you're you're
you know you're a princess that that
deserves to have a prince
and the numbers of princes are very very
low well
and the issue is you have girls that are
fours fives and sixes sleeping with
eights nines and tens and they think
they're on that level and so when they
actually meet the guy that's going to
marry them and is at their level that'll
put a ring on it they think they're
settling but they're not settling your
your level's what you can get
they're dating up then
there's their women sleep up
we have more data on this than ever
because we have dating app data which is
extremely honest so it says what what do
women want and it's between five to
fifteen percent of guys they're screwing
all the girls i mean i went to a pickup
artist boot camp which is
yeah i did this for a youtube video
where it's like basically a camp where
these guys teach other guys how to get
laid and they'll teach them things like
for example the girl's not going to want
to sleep with you if you haven't touched
her the whole date and that's something
you wouldn't really think about as a
woman like you know they touch your arm
touch your back that like builds
attraction
and
um like one of the dudes that was um
like teaching the camp i literally saw
him take home four girls in four days
and none of those girls were that cute
but but it's like those guys are
literally sleeping with everybody i'm
i'm surprised because i would have said
if you have to go to a pickup class to
get girls
he was the instructor
he wasn't the one
it was like oh my god they they spent a
lot of money on that camp so if any if
you ever want a business i pick up i'm
just interested why there were so many
girls at the men's pickup no it was just
me it wasn't a lot of girls it was oh
you mean no it was basically like they
would okay all these guys would fly to
vegas
and then at vegas they would
teach them how to get laid at like the
clubs and stuff so i did it as like a
vlog this is like i don't know you could
probably find it on my channel like six
months to a year ago
um yeah and i just wanted to see like
it's kind of like nosy like what are the
guys talking about
that
question is like
because we live in a really hyper
sexualized culture
like
i know like
i talk to my girlfriends and stuff and
they blatantly lie about how many guys
they've had sex with but a lot of guys
don't want virgins either
so it's like it's kind of a no-win
situation